in 2015 the afghan government announced
the taliban's former leader mullah omar
was dead
a senior taliban commander confirmed the
man who supported and gave shelter in
afghanistan to osama bin laden had died
two years earlier in a secret location
omar had been in hiding since soon after
the 9 11 attacks
[Music]
his son
yakub is believed to oversee the
taliban's military operations and has
been repeatedly proposed as an overall
leader of the armed group during
numerous leadership tussles
yakub reportedly turned down the offer
and proposed this man instead
akunzada is an islamic scholar often
described as the movement's supreme
leader
he took over the group's leadership when
his predecessor akhtar mansour was
killed in a u.s drone strike near the
afghan-pakistan border in 2016.
he has authority over the taliban's
political religious and military affairs
and is from one of the most powerful
pashtun clans
another prominent taliban leader is
he's played a leading role in
negotiations in doha that have tried to
reach a political settlement and lasting
peace in afghanistan
baradar is one of the co-founders of the
taliban and is head of its political
office he's believed to have been one of
muller omar's most trusted commanders
bharadha was captured in 2010 by
security forces in the southern
pakistani city of karachi he was
released in 2018
another important figure in the doha
negotiations and someone expected to
play a major role in the taliban's
leadership is share muhammad abbas
stanik zai
he's a former deputy minister in the
taliban's government before its removal
during the us-led invasion in 2001
and this is surajudin
he leads the powerful haqqani network a
group that has overseen the taliban's
financial and military assets across the
border in pakistan
the haqqani network has been blamed for
various attacks in afghanistan including
this one on the serena hotel in kabul in
2008.
it was also blamed for at least one of
the reported six assassination attempts
on the former president of afghanistan
hamid karzai
charles stratford al jazeera
well david derouch is a professor at the
national defense university and also a
former nato operations director at the
joint chiefs of staff he says time will
tell if the u.s mission was worth it or
not
we never fully addressed uh corruption
within the afghan government and what
we've seen here is not a military defeat
we've seen a failure of morale a
collapse of government where forces
decided not to fight
because they had no confidence in their
leaders what we're seeing is this idea
that you can build a modern military
without having a corresponding civilian
government and the it's like painting
over rust i mean we had a civilian
government that was fundamentally
corrupt and tribal we tried to build a
modern military to support it perhaps we
ignored the klaus witsiam imperative
that you have to have the people the
military you know and the government
and it failed there has been a
fundamental transformation of society in
afghanistan there's levels of education
and impairment of women
but if the taliban behaves the way they
did before you know as sort of a central
asian khmer rouge then they can reverse
that just through brutality